they're all just spokes on a wheel I'm
not going to stop the wheel I'm going to
break the wheel season 5 of Game of
Thrones is right around the corner
they've just confirmed that the
storyline of the show is gonna bypass
the storyline of the books you're gonna
see stuff in the show before you can
read about it we have a pretty good idea
of what that's gonna be
I'm drew Coolidge season for spoilers
left and right season 5 predictions
ahead this is hashtag news okay let's
get everyone caught up on how season 4
ended first of all the Lannisters Cersei
and Jaime have reaffirmed their love for
each other and they're about to find out
the daddy tie was dead Tyrion is on a
boat he was on trial for killing the
king his nephew what you did not do and
he escapes kills the hand of the king
his dad what she definitely did it Varys
who heard the bells and realized King's
Landing is about to go into turmoil was
like ah yeah I'm gonna go to her he's on
her way to Braavos to meet an old friend
bran is what tripping balls under a tree
with the Raven I think's on so it looks
like she's about to enjoy the little
finger the Hound is dead I think unless
he ends up being the luckiest character
in Game of Thrones Jon Snow just saved
man says life he's hanging out with
Stannis threat to the throne Baratheon
those two are really hitting it off all
while trying to get over a grip hey oh
and the White Walkers are still making
their way towards the wall when they're
not turning baby's eyes who is that guy
seriously it looks like the blue devil
if you had a theory put it in the
comments everyone's favorite Khaleesi
has sent away her favorite trusty
advisor she's locked up her little
cutesy babies and for some reasons
decided to be a mayor of this city
instead of ruler of all of Westeros now
huh okay prediction time here's what we
can piece together about season five
from the trailers I think Margaery is
still queen although now she's married
to the non evil blonde kid Tommen who's
still the product of incest and here's
the thing since Tywin was basically the
puppeteer behind Joffrey and now Tommen
he's dead
that leaves kind of a power vacuum and I
think is gonna be filled by the grandma
Queen of thorns Tyrell the Lannisters
are not gonna like that first of all
they have a bunch of debt that daddy
left them we don't know what's gonna
happen to catch to the Iraq and Circe's
daughter is in Dorne
the place where over and is from the guy
that Cersei just got head smushed they
don't like the Lannisters too much
here's my prediction Jaime Lannister is
gonna team up with brought his current
sword fighting instructor and go on some
crazy killing rescue mission to save
their daughter oh it's his daughter too
it's his daughter too
sex Daenerys is not gonna do well in
Mereen their statues falling over
there's gonna be an uprising
I think tyrion and varys will swoop in
join sides with her and put her finally
back on her mission to take over
Westeros in the trailer we see arya pick
up that sword i think she's gonna start
training in Braavos maybe with the
faceless man who knows she's still got a
list full of people who need her good
old-fashioned killing Jon Snow as always
knows nothing he's in a tricky spot
he's got Stannis on one side who wants
him to join up probably there's mance
and he's still technically a part of the
Nights Watch which is run by boy King
Tommen here's my prediction Jon Snow
doesn't care about who rules Westeros
he's just trying to get people together
to fight the White Walkers if there's
one thing John Snow cares about its
segregation of the races White Walkers
here Castle black over here and here's
the big news the show's creators have
announced it's official the show's
storyline is gonna pass the books here's
how we think it's gonna go down Arya's
current storyline is really close to
where the books are so unless they try
to stretch her storyline out like crazy
I think we're gonna see some new Arya
stuff soon and as we all know Game of
Thrones loves their big battle sequences
they average about one big battle per
season well there's two battles in the
books that have been talked about but
never revealed my money's on the show
getting to that battle first so like
this video if you like Game of Thrones
everyone that's not cheating that's just
piggybacking off of something we all
love sure okay good
go ahead and comment below with your own
predictions and who's that Blue Devil
god answer me Gary its name is Gary you
talking about yeah that's Gary he was
the center on my basketball team and
subscribe if you want to see more videos
like this where we get to talk about our
favorite shows with each other do it do
it do it do it do it they get it alright
let's move on this has been hash tag
news I'm drew Coolidge and everyone sing
along with me now game of Game of
Thrones Game of Thrones Game of Thrones
Terry
groaning aah aah crowd groans came
across from came across our dragons